the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so how many people have ever heard of
silk have used it so those of you who've
used it may may find this talk old or
whatever but so silk is a system that
runs on a shared memory multiprocessors
so this is not like the system you've
been programming for this class this
kind of machine you have processors
which you have cache and some sort of a
network and a bunch of memory and when
the processors do memory operations they
are all on the same address space and
it's typically you know the memory
system provides some sort of coherence
like strong consistency or maybe release
consistency the you know we're
interested in the case where the
distance from processors to other
processors into processors to memory may
be non-uniform and so it's important to
use the cache well in this kind of
machine because you can't just hope to
you can't just ignore the cache so the
sort of the technology that I'm going to
talk about for this kind of system is
called silk silk is AC language and it
does dynamic multi-threading and
has a provably good runtime system so
I'll talk about what those all mean silk
runs on shared memory machines like sons
and SGI's and why you probably can't
find alpha servers anymore
it runs on SMPS like it better in
everybody's laptops now there's been a
several interesting applications over
written and inseok including virus shell
assembly graphics rendering and body
simulation we did a bunch of chess
programs because they were sort of the
raison d'être for silk and silk one of
the features about silk is that it
automatically manages a lot of the
low-level issues you don't have to do
load balancing you don't have to write
in protocols you write and you know you
basically write programs that look a lot
more like the ordinary syrup programs
instead of saying well first time first
I'm gonna do this and then I'm going to
set this variable and then somebody else
is gonna read that variable and that's a
protocol and those are very difficult to
to get right yeah I'll mention that we
had award-winning chess players so to
explain what sucks about I'll talk about
Fibonacci Fibonacci this is just to
review in case you don't know see you
almost see right
so spin Bonacci is the function that's
you know each number is the sum of the
previous two Fibonacci numbers and this
is an implementation that basically does
that computation directly the Fibonacci
of n if n is less the two it's just n so
Fibonacci of 0 is 0 and 1 is 1/2 the
Fibonacci's well then you have to do the
recursion so you compute Fibonacci of n
minus 1 and Fibonacci of n minus 2 and
sum them together and that's Fibonacci
of n one observation about this function
is it's a really slow implementation of
Fibonacci right you don't know how to do
this faster how fast can you do
Fibonacci you all know this ok so how
fast is this one
so-so so for those of you don't know you
can you can you know you sort of know
how to compute Fibonacci
in linear time just by keeping track of
the most recent - right so if you know
one one two three five you just do it
this is exponential time and there is an
algorithm that does it in logarithmic
time so this fun this implementation is
doubly exponentially bad but it's good
as a didactic example because it's easy
to understand so to turn this into soap
we just add some keywords and I'll talk
about what the keywords are in a minute
but the key thing to understand about
this is if you delete the keywords you
have a C program and so programs have
the property that one of the legal
semantics for the soap program is the C
program that you get by deleting the
keywords now there's other possible
semantics you could get because not for
this function this function always
produces the same answer because there's
no race conditions in it but for
programs that have races you may have
other semantics that the system could
provide and so this kind of a language
extension where you can sort of delete
the extensions and get a a correct
implementation of the parallel program
is called a faithful extension a lot of
languages like OpenMP have properties
that if you you have these directives
and if you delete them it will change
the semantics of your program and so you
have to be very careful now if you're
careful about programming OpenMP you can
make it so that it's faithful that that
has this property but it's not always
the case that it is no c89 but
so the issue of restricted pointers for
example so so kid you know turns out to
work with c99 as well so the sub
compiler makes no assumptions about that
if you write a program and you're in the
backend silk is it so so works I'll talk
about this in a couple minutes silk
works by transforming this into a c
program that has four in when you run it
on one processor it's just the original
C program in effect and so if you have a
dialect of C that has restricted
pointers and a compiler that knows you
make a mistake if you make a mistake the
language doesn't stop you from making a
program that has a race condition in it
would still be valid it will just have a
race in it it would have a non-terminal
result may not do what you want but one
of the legal executions of that parallel
program is the original C program very
sort of level of doing analysis silk
doesn't do analysis silk is a compiler
that compiles you know this language and
the semantics are what they are which is
you know the spawn it's it's I'll talk
about the semantics the spawn means you
can run the function in parallel and if
that doesn't give you the same answer
every time it's not the compilers fall
that's pardon
one of the legal things the silk system
could do is just run this run that
program now if you're running it on
multiple processors that's not what
happens because the other things there's
some performance guarantees we give so
there's actually parallelism but on one
processor in fact that's exactly what
the execution does so silk does dynamic
multi-threading and this is different
from P threads for example where you
have these very heavyweight threads that
cost tens of thousands of instructions
to create silk threads are really small
so in this in this program there's a
silk thread that runs basically from
when the fib starts to here and then I
feel like I'm I guess I feel like
there's some missing slide in here
didn't tell you about spawn okay well
let me tell you about spawn because what
the spawn means is that this function
can run in parallel that's very simple
what the sync means is that all the
functions that were spawned off in this
function all have to finish before this
function can proceed so in a normal
execution of C when you call a function
the parent stops and soak the parent can
keep running so while that's running the
parent you know this can spawn off this
and then the sync happens and now the
parent has to stop and this keyword
basically just says that this function
can be spawned see the sync is the sake
is scoped within the function so if you
have a for loop that spawned off a whole
bunch of stuff
there's an implicit sync at the end of
every function so cell functions are
strict right so there's there's children
down inside here but this function can't
return well if I omitted the sink and
some down in some leaf the compiler puts
one in and before the function returns
so you can't there's some there's some
of languages that are like this where
somehow the intermediate functions can
go away and then you have to then you
can sync directly with your grandparent
this gives you this DAGs you have this
part of the program that runs up to the
first spawn and then the part of the
program that runs between the spawns and
then the part of the program that runs
after this well between this after the
last spawn to the sink and then from
there to the return so I've got this
this drawing that shows that this this
function sort of grow running so first
the purple code runs and he gets to the
spawn it spawns off this guy but now the
second piece of code can start running
so he does a spawn so these two are
running in parallel meanwhile this guy
started that off and this is a base case
so he's gonna not do anything he's just
gonna because I'm doing before and just
feels like there's some something
missing in this slide oh wow
essentially now this guy couldn't run
going back to here this function this
part of the code couldn't run until
after the sink so this thing is sitting
here waiting so when that when these
guys finally return then this can run
this guy's getting stuck here he runs
and these runs these two returned and
value comes up here and now basically
the function is done one observation
here is that there's no mention of the
number of processors in this code just
you haven't specified how to schedule or
anything processors all you specified is
this directed acyclic graph that unfolds
dynamically and it's up to us to
schedule those under the processors so
this code is processor oblivious it's
oblivious to the number of processors
now what you do is you write as many
spawns as you can suppose all the
parallels in your code okay so you want
this bag to have millions of threads in
it concurrently and then it's up to us
to schedule that efficiently so it's a
different mindset then let me I have
four processors let me create four
things to do I have four processors let
me create a million things to do and
then then the soap scheduler guarantees
to give you you have four processors
I'll give you four fold speed-up that
you do here in order to make the leaf
code there's some overhead for doing
function calls so it's small overhead it
turns that's like the cost of a spawn is
like three function calls so you end up
wanting to you were actually trying to
make this code run faster you make the
base case bigger and do something you
know do some speed things up a little
bit of the leads of this this caller so
this is culture e and inside the call
tree is this day soap supports C's rule
for pointers whatever for whatever
dialect you have if you have a pointer
to a stack that's and then you make you
have a pointer into the stack and then
you call you're allowed to use that
pointer in C and so in silk you are as
well if you have a parallel thing going
on where normally and seeing you is
called a then B returns than C and D so
C and D can refer to anything on a but
so you can't legally refer to something
on B and the same rule applies in silk
so we have a data structure that
implements this cactus stack that's what
it's called after the saguaro cactus the
sorceress imagery there and it lets you
support that rule there's some advanced
features in soap that had to do with
speculative execution and I'm gonna skip
over those today because it turns out
that sort of 99% of the time you don't
need this stuff and we have some
debugger support so if you've written
code that relied on some semantics that
maybe you didn't like when you went to
the parallel world you'd like to find
out so this this is this is a tool that
basically takes a soap program in an
input data set and it runs and it tells
you is there any schedule that I could
have chosen this is that directed
acyclic graph so there's a whole bunch
of possible schedules I could have
chosen is there any schedule that
changes the order of two concurrent
memory operations where one of them is a
right so we call this the non
determinate ER because it finds all the
determinacy races in your program and so
guarantees the self race detector is
guaranteed to find those there's a lot
of race detectors where if the race
doesn't actually occur you have two
things that are logically in parallel
but if they don't actually run on
different processors a lot of the grace
detectors out there in the world won't
report the race you get false negatives
and there's a bunch of false positives
that show up this basically only gives
you the real ways so this doesn't
analyze the program it analyzes the
execution and so it's not trying to
solve some np-complete problem we return
complete problem right it's trying to
and so this reduces the problem of
finding data races to the situation
that's just like when you're trying to
do source code release and quality
control for serial programs you write
tests if you don't test your program you
don't know what it does and that's the
same property here you have to if you do
find some race some day later then you
can write a test for it and be and know
that you're testing to make sure that
race didn't creep back into your code
and that's what you want out of a
software release strategy
right so this will if they're as long as
the code does if you starts putting in
sync someday a sync then maybe the race
goes away because of that but if you
just put in you know instrumentation to
try figure out what's going on it's
still there the race detector sort of
says uh you know this variable in this
function and this variable in this
function you look at it and say how
could that happen and finally you figure
it out and you fix it and then you put
it if you're trying to do software
release you build a regression test that
will verify that that's not you know
that has that input
yes the race detect for example our
resident understands locks so part of
the rule is it doesn't report a race if
the tool operates two memory accesses if
there was a lock that they both held in
common you could now you now you can
write buggy programs because you could
essentially do a memory you know lock
you know read the memory unlock lock
write the memory and now the interleave
happens and there's a race so the
assumption of this race detector is that
if you put locks in there that you sort
of thought about it this is finding
races that you forgot about rather than
races that you ostensibly thought about
there's some races that you that are
actually correct for example in the
chess program there's this big table
that remembers all the chess positions
that have been seen and if you don't get
the right answer out of the table it
doesn't matter because you just searched
it again anyway not getting the right
answer means you don't get any answer
you look something up and it's not there
so you search again and if you just
waited a little longer maybe that
somebody else would have put the value
and you could have saved a little work
and so in that case well it turns out to
be there's no parallel way to do that so
you say oh I'm willing to tolerate that
race because that gives me performance
and so you pull we have what we call
fake locks which are basically things
that look like lock calls but they don't
do anything except tell the race
detector pretend that there was a lock
held in common yeah
if you report a race on it tells you
about that if it says there's no race it
means that for every possible scheduling
that well so you have that dag and
imagine running it on one processor
there's a lot of possible orders in
which to run the dag right and the rule
is well was there was there a load in us
and a store or a store in a store that
switched orders in some possible
schedule and that's the definition
those protocols are really hard to get
right but yes it's a bit too important
trick so to convince the race to dictor
not to complain you put fake locks
around them and and then you have to you
know you've programmed a sophisticated
algorithm it's up to you to get the
details right right this is just right
this is so the other property about this
race detector is that it's fast it runs
almost in linear time a lot of the race
detectors that you find out there run in
quadratic time so if you want to run a
million instructions that has to compare
every instruction to every other
instruction it turns out we don't have
to do that we run in time which is N
times alpha of n where alpha is the
inverse Ackermann function anybody
remember that from the union-find
algorithm it's hard that it's got that
buried in it so it's like the almost
linear time and we actually now have a
linear time one that is has some
performance advantages so let me do a
little theory in practice and soak we
have some fundamental complexity
measures that we worry about we're
interested in knowing and being able to
predict the run time of a Silk program
on P processors so we want to know T sub
P which is the execution time on P
processors that's the goal what we've
got to work with is some directed
acyclic graph that for at least for a
particular input set and if the program
is determinate and everything else it's
a well-defined graph and we can come up
with some basic measures of this graph
so t1 is the work of the graph which is
the total time it would take to run that
graph on one processor or if you assume
that these things are all cost unit time
it's just the number of nodes so for
this graph what's the work
I did I could I heard teen but something
18c and the critical path is the longest
path and if these nodes weren't unit
time you have to wait the things
according to actually how much time they
run so the critical path here is what
nine so I think those are right the
lower bounds then that you know is that
you don't expect the runtime on P
processors to be faster than linear
speed-up in this model it doesn't happen
now you know it turns out cache does
things that's adding more than just
processors right you're adding more cash
to and so all sorts of things or maybe
you've maybe you should maybe it means
that there's a better algorithm you
should have used so there's some funny
things that happen if you have bad
algorithms and so forth but in this
model you can't have better more than
linear speed-up you also can't get
things done faster than in linear time
this model assumes basically that these
costs of running these things are fixed
and the cash change cache has the
property that changing the order of
execution means that the control costs
of the nodes and the graph change costs
so so those are lower bounds and the
things that we want to know are speed up
so that's t1 over TP and the parallelism
of the graph is T 1 over T infinity so
the work over the critical path and
we've been calling this span sometimes
lately some people call that depth span
is easier to say than critical path
depth has too many other meanings so I
kind of like span so what's the
parallelism for this program
you guys the critic he said the t1 was
what 18 he and vinegar is nine so on
average and if you had an infinite
number of processors and you scheduled
this as greedy's you could this is you
know it would take you nine steps to run
and you would be doing 18 things worth
of work so on on average there's two
things to do 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 3 plus
4 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 plus 1/9 turns
out to be 2 so the average parallelism
or just the parallelism of the program
is T 1 over T infinity and this property
is something that's not dependent on the
scheduler it's a property of the program
doesn't depend on how many processors
you have
but that's too long to say all right
might as well say critical path length
right critical path length longest trade
span is a mathematical sounding name
well yeah so there's a theorem due to
Graham and Brent that said that there's
some schedule that can actually achieve
the sum of those two lower bounds when
you're speed up is one lower bound to
the run time and the critical path was
the other so there's some schedule that
basically achieves the sum of those and
how does that theorem work well at each
time step either suppose we had three
processors either there's at least three
things ready to run and so what you do
is you do a greedy schedule you'd grab
any three of them right if there's fewer
than P things to run like here we have a
situation where these have all run the
green ones are ready to go and those are
the only two that are ready to go so
what do you do then in a greedy schedule
you run them all right and the argument
goes the argument goes well how many
time steps could you execute three
things at most you could do it that work
divided by the number of processors
times right because then after that
you've used up all the work well how
many times could you execute less than P
things well every time you execute less
than P things you're reducing the length
of the remaining critical path so you
can't do that more than the span times
and so a greedy scheduler will achieve
some runtime which is within the sum of
these two it's actually the sum of these
two minus one it turns out that there
has to be at least one node that's on
both work and critical paths and so that
means that you're guaranteed to be
within a factor of two of optimal with a
greedy scheduler and it turns out that
if you have a lot of parallelism
compared to the number of processors
so if you have a graph that has a
million fold parallelism and a thousand
fold processor as well if this is really
small compared to the work right if you
have a graph with a million fold
parallelism that means the critical path
is small if you only had a thousand
processors that means this terms big and
that means that this term is very close
to this term so essentially the
corollary to this is that you get linear
speed-up perfect linear speed-up
asymptotic Li if you have fewer
processors than you have parallelism
your program so the game here at this
level of understanding we haven't told
you have the scheduler actually works
it's too bright a program that's got a
lot of parallelism so that you can get
linear speed-up okay well the work
stealing scheduler we actually use the
problem is the greedy schedulers can be
hard to compute especially if you
imagine having a million processors in a
program with a billion fold parallelism
finding on every clock cycle finding
something for each of the million guys
to do is you know conceptually difficult
so instead we we have a work stealing
scheduler and I'll talk about that in a
second it achieves bounds which are not
quite as good as that those there this
bound is the same it's the sum of two
terms one is the linear speed-up term
but instead of it being T infinity its
big o of T infinity because you actually
have to do communication sometimes if
the critical path length is long
basically you can sort of imagine if you
have a lot of things to do a lot of
tasks and people to do it it's easy to
do that in parallel if there's no inter
dependencies among the tasks but as soon
as there's dependencies you end up
having to coordinate a lot and that
communication costs you know this is
lots of lore about adding programmers to
a task and it's slowing you down right
because basically the communication gets
you what we found empirically that's
that there's a theorem for this what
empirically the the the runtime is
actually still very close to the some of
those terms or maybe it's those terms
plus two times
infinity or something like that and
again we basically get near-perfect
speed up as long as the number of
processors is a lot less than the
parallelism should be sort of a less
than less than and we provide the
compiler rinse well in the compiler has
a mode where you basically can insert
instrumentation so you can run your
program it'll tell you the critical path
length you can compute these numbers
right so you clear how to compute work
you just sum up the caught runtime of
all the threads to compute the critical
path length well you have to do some
maxes and stuff as you go through the
graph and the average cost of a spawn
these days is about three on a like a
dual core Pentium three times the cost
of a function call and most of that cost
is actually has to do with the memory
barrier that we do at the spawn because
that machine doesn't have strong
consistency so you have to put this
memory barrier in and that just empties
all the pipeline's
much much does better on like an SGI
machine which has strong a traditional
and a mips machine that has strong
consistency actually does better for the
cost of that overhead so let me talk a
little bit about chess and we had a
bunch of chess programs I wrote one in
1994 which placed third at the
international computer Chess
Championship and that was running on a
big connection machine cm 5 and I was
one of the architects of that machine so
it was double fun we wrote another
program that plays second in 95 and that
was running on an 1800 node Paragon and
that was a big computer back then we
built another program called silk chess
which placed first in 96 running on a
relatively smaller port machine and then
on a larger SGI
origin we ran some more and then at the
world computer Chess Championship in
1999 we beat deep blue and lost to a PC
and people don't realize this but at the
time that deep blue beat Kasparov it was
not the world computer Chess Champion a
PC was
so what it's running a program so you
know there's this head and tape so this
was a program called Fritz which is a
commercially available program and those
guys were very good
you know those PC guys playing we're
very good at getting on sort of the
algorithms side they were you get some
you know we got advantage by brute force
and and we also had some real chess
expertise on our team but those guys
were spending full time on on things
like pruning away branch sub-sub
searches that you can that they were
convinced weren't gonna pan out computer
chess program spend most of their time
looking at situations that any person
would look at and say wow blacks won why
are you even looking at this and it
keeps searching and I said well maybe
there's a way to get the Queen so
computers are pretty dumb at that so
basically these guys put a lot more
chess intelligence in and and we also
lost due to what in this particular game
we were tied for first place and we
decided to do a runoff game to find out
who would win and we lost due to a
classic horizon effect so it turns out
that we were searching to depth 12 and
this in the tree and Fritz was searching
to depth 11 even with all this this
heuristics and stuff they had in it they
were still not searching as deeply as we
were but there was again a move that was
a good move that looked okay at depth 11
and looked bad at depth 12 and a depth
13 it looked really good again so they
saw the move and made it for the wrong
reason we saw the move and didn't make
it for the right reason but it was wrong
and the right move if we'd been able to
search a little deeper we would have
seen that it was you know really the
wrong thing to do so as a you know this
happens all the time of chests there's a
little randomness in there this horizon
effect shows up and it again it boils
down to the program's are not
intelligent a human would look at it and
say eventually that night's going to
fall but if the computer can't see it
with a search you know
so we we plotted the speed up of star
Socrates which was the first one on this
funny graph so this looks sort of like a
typical linear speed-up graph sort of
when you're down here with few numbers
processors you get good linear speed-up
and eventually you stop getting linear
speed-up that's sort of in broad strokes
what this graph looks like right
but the axes are kind of funny the axes
aren't the number of processors and the
speed-up it's the number of processors
divided by the parallelism of the
program and here it's the speed-up
divided by the parallelism of the
program and the reason we did that is
that each of these data points is a
different program with different work
and span and so if I have a different
you know if I'm if I'm trying to run a
particular problem on a bunch of
different processors I can just draw
that curve and see what happens as I run
get more processors I I no longer need
you know I'm not getting any advantage
because I've got too many processors
I've exceeded the parallelism of the
program but if I'm running trying to
compare two different programs how do I
do that well you can do that by
normalizing by the parallelism so down
in this domain the number of processors
is small compared to the average
parallelism and we get good linear speed
ups and up in this domain the number of
processors is large and it starts a some
toting to the point where the speed-up
approaches the parallelism and that's
sort of what happens and you get some
noise out here so one of the things down
here it's nice and tight right and
that's because we're in that domain
where the communication costs are
infrequently paid because there's lots
of work to do you don't have to
communicate very much up here there's a
lot of communication that happens and so
the noise is showing up more in the data
so that it's like this this curve here
is the t1 over P plus T infinity curve
and that's the the TP equals T infinity
curve and that's the linear speed-up
curve on this graph so it so I think you
know there's an important lesson in this
graph
besides the data itself which is if
you're careful about choosing the the
axes you can
a whole bunch of data that you couldn't
see how to plot it together and you can
plot it together and get something
meaningful so in my PhD thesis I had
hundreds of little plots for each
petrest position and I didn't figure out
how it's like they all looked the same
right but I didn't sort of figure out
that if I was careful I could actually
make them be the same that happened
after I published my thesis oh we could
just overlay him well what's the
normalization that makes that work so
there's a speed-up paradox that happened
pardon yeah okay there was a speed-up
paradox that happened in while we were
developing star Socrates we were
developing this for a 512 processor
connection machine that was at
University of Illinois but we only had a
smaller machine on which to do our
development we had 128 processor machine
at MIT and most days I could only get 32
processors because the machine was in
heavy demand so we had this program and
it ran on 32 processors in 65 seconds
and one of the developers said here's a
variation on the algorithm it changes
the the dag it's a heuristic it makes
the program run more efficient look it
runs in only 40 seconds on 32 processors
and so is that a good idea it sure
seemed like a good idea but we were
worried that the we knew that the
transformation increased the critical
path length of the program so we weren't
sure it was a good idea so we did some
calculation we measured the work and the
speed-up and so the work here and these
numbers have been cooked a little bit to
make the math easy but the numbers this
really did happen but not with these
exact numbers so we had a work which was
2048 seconds and only one second of
critical path and over this new program
had only half as much work to do but the
critical path length was longer it was 8
seconds long so if you measure it on 30
if you predict on 32 processors what the
runtimes going to be that formulas as
well 65 seconds and if you predict it on
32 processors there's well it's 40
chickens and it looked good but we were
gonna running to be running the
tournament on 512 processors where the
this term would start being less
important than this term so this and
this really did happen and we actually
went back and validated that these
numbers were right after we did the
calculation and it was like it allowed
us to do the engineering to make the
right decision and not be misled by
something that looked good in the in the
test environment we were able and we
were able to predict what was going to
happen on the big machine without
actually having access to the big
machine and that was very important let
me do some algorithms you guys probably
done some matrix multiplies over the
past three weeks right that's probably
the only thing you've been able to do so
matrix multiplication is this operation
I won't talk about it but you know what
it is in silk instead of doing the
standard you know triply nested loops
you do divide and conquer
we don't parallel wise loops we parallel
eyes function calls so you want to
express loops as recursion so to
multiply two big matrices you do a whole
bunch of little matrix multiplications
of the sub-blocks and then you express
those little matrix multiplications
themselves go off and recursively do
smaller matrix multiplications so this
requires eight multiplications of
matrices of half the number of rows and
half the number of columns and one
addition at the end where you add these
two matrices together that's the
algorithm for that we do four it's the
same total work as the standard one but
it's just expressed recursively so
matrix multiply is you do these eight
multiplies I had to create a temporary
variable so the first four multiplies
multiply eight the A's and B's in to see
the second four multiply the A's and B's
into T and then I have to add T in to C
so I do all those spawns do all the
multiplies I do a sync because I better
not start using the results on the
multiplies and adding them until the
multiplies are done then I stood what
just
all right matrix matrix addition
well we spawn off at so you have to
spawn sub functions even if you are only
executing one of them at a time
okay so functions are spawn C functions
are called it's it's a decision that's
built in the language it's not really a
fundamental decision it's just you know
that's the way we did it yeah we found
that I've made our code more or we were
less likely to make a mistake if we sort
of built it into the type system in this
way but I'm not convinced that this is
the best way to do this this type system
no you can only call spawn spawn spawn
spawn then you can call C functions at
the leaves it turns out you can actually
cut spawn sub functions if you're a
little clever about there's a mechanism
for just a silk system running in the
background and if you're running C you
can say okay do this soap function in
parallel so we have that but that's not
that's not didactic you know it's so
inside the function it actually just
start processing so long as it's
guaranteeing that the results are
available before yes so there's this
other style of expressing curls in which
you see in some of the data flow
languages where you say well you know
I've computed this first multiply why
can't I get started on the corresponding
part of the addition all right and it
turns out that in those models there's
no performance guarantees the real
issues you run out of memory it's a long
topic let's not go into it but there's
there's a serious technical issue with
those those programming models is that
we only use we have very tight memory
bounds as well so it simultaneously get
these good scheduling bounds and good
memory bounds and if you are doing that
you could have sort of a really large
amount number of temporaries required
you run out of memory the data flow
machines used to have this number there
was the student Kent Rabb who was
working on monsoon when Greg
Papadopoulos was here and he came up
with this term called which we called
Rob's constant which was how long the
machine could be run guaranteed to run
before it crashed from being out of
memory and that was well he took the
rate at which it could scons divide it
by the number amount of memory and that
was it
and many dataflow programs had that
property the monsoon could run for 40
seconds and then after that you never
knew it might start crash at any moment
so everybody wrote short dataflow
programs so one of the things you
actually do when you're implementing
when you're trying to engineer this to
go fast is you Basin your course in the
base case which I didn't describe up
there you don't just do a one by one
matrix multiply down there at the leaves
of this recursion you call because then
you're not using the processor pipeline
efficiently you have to you call the
Intel math kernal library or something
on a 8x8 matrix so that it really gets
the pipeline a chance to chug away so
analysis this matrix addition operation
well how long what's the work for matrix
of addition well the work to do a matrix
operation on n rows is well you have to
do four additions of size n over two
plus there's order one work here for the
sink and that recurrence has solution
order N squared well that's not
surprising you have to add up two
matrices which are n by n you know it's
gonna be N squared so it's that's a good
result the critical path for this is
well you have to do all of these in
parallel so whatever the critical path
of the longest one is they're all the
same so it's just the critical path of
the size n over 2 plus order 1 so the
critical path is order log n for matrix
multiplication they're sort of the
reason I do this is I can write it's
like this gives this is a model in which
I can do this analysis so I have to do
it right but it really you know that
being able to do this analysis is
important when you're trying to make
things run faster
matrix multiplication well the work is I
have to do eight little matrix
multiplies plus I have to do the matrix
add so the work that that the work has
solution order n cubed and everybody
knows that there's order and cube MIT
multiply adds in a matrix multiply so
that's not very surprising the critical
path is well I have to do a ad so that
takes login plus I have to do a multiply
on a matrix that's half the size so the
critical path length of the whole thing
has solution order log squared n so the
total parallelism of matrix
multiplication is the work over the span
which is n cubed over log squared n so
if you have a thousand by thousand
matrix that means your parallelism is
close to ten million there's a lot of
parallelism and in fact we see perfect
linear speed-up on matrix multiply
because there's so much parallelism in
it
it turns out that this stack temporary
that I created so that I could do these
multiplies all in parallel is actually
costing me work because I'm on a machine
that has cash and I want to use the cash
effectively so I really don't want to
create a whole big temporary matrix and
blow my cash out if I can avoid it what
I so I propose the following matrix
multiply which is I first do four of the
matrix multiplies into c1 and I do a
sync and then I do the other foreign to
C one and another sync and I forgot to
do yeah those are multiplied adds so
they're multiplying and adding in and
this saves space because it doesn't need
a temporary but it increases the
critical path so is that a good idea or
a bad idea well we can answer part of
that question with analysis it's gonna
saving space we know is gonna save
something but what does it do to the
working critical path well the work is
still the same it's n cubed because we
didn't change the number of flops that
we're doing but the critical path has
grown instead of doing one times a
matrix multiply we have to do one and
then sync and then do another one so
it's two matrix multiplies of half the
size plus the order one and that
recurrence has had solution order n
instead of order log squared n so that
sounds bad we've made the critical path
longer what yeah so parallelism is now
order N squared instead of n cubed over
log squared n and for a thousand by
thousand matrix that means you still
have a million fold parallelism so for
relatively modest size matrices you
still have plenty of work to do this
optimization so this is a good
transformation to do and one of the
advantages of silk is that you can do
this kind of transformation you can say
well let me do an optimization and I can
do an optimization in my C code and I
get to take advantage of it in the soak
coder I could do this kind of
optimization of trading work for
parallelism if I have a lot of work that
sometimes is a good idea ordinary matrix
multiplication just is really bad
basically you can imagine spawning off
the N squared inner dot products here
and compute it them all in parallel it
has work n cubed parallelism log n so it
has I mean critical path log n so the
parallelism is even better it's log it's
n cubed over log n instead of N squared
so that's that looks better
theoretically but it's really bad in
practice because it has such poor cache
behavior so we don't do that I'll just
briefly talk about how it works so Silk
does work stealing we have this double
ended queue or deque so at the bottom of
the queue is the stack where you push
and pop things and the top is something
where you can pop things off if you want
to and so what's running is all these
processors are running each on their own
stack they're all running the ordinary
serial code that's sort of the basic
situation they're pretty much running
the serial code most of the time so some
processor runs it pushes well it does a
spawn so what does it do it pushes
something onto its stack because it's
just a function call and it does another
a couple more spawns so things pop off
somebody returns so he pops his stack so
far everything's going on they're not
communicating they're completely
independent computations this guy spawns
and now he's out of work he now he have
to do something what he does is he goes
and picks another processor at random
and he steals the thing at from the
other end of the stack so he's unlikely
to conflict because this guy's pushing
and popping down here but there is a
lock in there there's a little algorithm
a non-blocking
algorithm actually it's not not locking
and so he goes and he steals something
and come on slide over there whoa
yes that's animation right that's the
extent of my animation and then he
starts working away and the theorem is
that a work stealing scheduler like this
gives expected running time with high
probability actually of t1 over P plus T
infinity on P processors and the pseudo
proof is a little bit like the proof for
Brent's theorem which is either you're
working or stealing if you're working
well that goes against T 1 over T over P
you can't do that very
you run out of work if you're stealing
well each steal has a chance that it
steals the thing that it's on the
critical path you may actually steal the
wrong thing but you actually have a 1 in
P chance that you're the one who steals
the thing that if only that it's on the
critical path and in which case the
expected number so you have this chance
of 1 over P of reducing the critical
path length by 1 so after this many
steals the critical path is all gone so
you can only do P over T and P times T
infinity steals with high probability it
turns out and that gives you these
bounds okay I'm not gonna give you all
this stuff it's message-passing sucks
you know it's probably nothing else in
here so basically you know the pitch
here is that you get some high-level
linguistic support for this very fine
grained parallelism
it's an algorithmic programming model so
that means that you can do engineering
for performance there's a fairly easy
conversion of existing codes especially
when you combine it with the race
detector you've got this factorization
of the debugging problem into debugging
your serial code as you run it with all
the silk stuff turned off you elide the
program and make sure your program works
then you run it with a race detector to
make sure you get the same answer in
parallel and then you're done
applications in silk don't just scale to
large number of processors they scale
down to small numbers which is important
if you only have two processors or one
you don't suddenly want to pay a factor
of 10 to get off the ground which
happens sometimes on clusters running
MPI you have to pay a big overhead
before you've made any progress and one
of the advantages for example is that
the number of processors might change
dynamically and this model that's ok
because it's not part of the program so
you may have the operating system reduce
the number of actual worker threads that
you have it's doing that worth stealing
and that can work one of the bad things
about silk is that it doesn't support
sort of
data-parallel or program model kind of
executing of parallelism if you you know
you really have to think of things as
this divide and conquer kind of the
world and if you have trouble expressing
that you know situations where you're
you know you're doing Jacobi update and
you've very carefully put things on you
know put had each processor work on its
local memory and then they only have to
communicate at the boundaries that's
difficult to do right in self because
essentially every time you go around the
loop of all these things to do all the
work stealing happens randomly and it
happens on a different processor so it's
not very good at that sort of thing
although it turns out Jacobi updates not
a very good example that for that
because there are more sophisticated
algorithms that use cache effectively
that you can express and silk and I
would no I have no idea how to you know
say those in some of these sort of data
parallel languages and using the cache
efficiently is really important on
modern processors you can download silk
there's a bunch of contributors those
are the silkworms and you can download
silk off our web page just Google for
silk and you'll find it it's a great
language love it you'll love it much
more than what you've been doing
well you have to have a language that
can compiler that can generate those if
you have an assembly command or you have
some other compiler that can generate
those so I just won the HPC challenge
which is this challenge where everybody
in tries to run the parallel programs
and argue that they get productivity for
that there were some codes like matrix
multiply and Lu decomposition of
pivoting basically at the leaves of the
computation I called the Intel math
kernal library which in turn uses the
SSE instructions so that you could do
anything you can do and see in the C
parts of the code because the silk
compiler just passes those through and
so if you have some really efficient
pipeline code for doing something you
know up to some point it made it make
sense to use that because you so I ran
it on NASA's Columbia once each so I so
the benchmark consists of well there's
seven applications they have six of
which are actually well defined one of
them is this thing that just measures
network performance for something so it
doesn't have any real semantics so
there's six benchmarks one of them is Lu
decomposition one of them is DJ matrix
multiplication and there's FFT and three
others so I implemented all six nobody
else implemented all six it turns out
that you had to implement three in order
to enter almost everybody yet
implemented three or four but I did all
six which is part of why I won cuz I
could argue that in a week's worth I
interested in a week's work I just
implemented so there so the prize gets
the prize has two components performance
and productivity or elegance or
something and it's completely whatever
the judges want us to want that to be so
it was up to me as a presenter to make
the case that I was elegant cuz I had my
performance numbers which were pretty
good and it turned out that the IBM
entry for X tended me more good than I
did I think because they got up there
and they compared the performance of X
10 to they're silk implementation and
their X 10 thing was almost as good as
silk so after that I think the judges
said they had to give me the price so
basically went down to supercomputing in
each of us got five minutes to present
and there were five five finalists and
we enter you know we did our
presentation and then they gave out the
so they gave the people at they gave up
they divided the prize three ways the
people got the absolute best performance
which were some people running UPC and
the people who had the most elegance
based on minimum number of lines of
codes and that was clot cleave at what's
his name the math works guy the MATLAB
guy who said look matrix Lu
decomposition
Lu of PEEP and it's like so that's very
elegant but I don't think that it really
sort of explains what you have to do to
solve the problems so he won the prize
for most elegance and I got the prize
for best combination which they then
changed the tight in the front and the
final citation for the prize they said
most productivity that was the price so
I actually won the contest because that
was what the contest was supposed to be
was most productivity but I only won a
third of the prize money because they
divided it